blade Smiths welcome back to the forge
this is a Redemption challenge each of
you suffered excruciating losses in your
respective competitions that sent you
home without the title of forged and
fire Champion or that 10 grand but
because you all showed skill and
tenacity you've been given another
opportunity to compete for those things
in front of our panel of expert judges
all right gentlemen you'll notice that
your anvils are be the only steel that
we'll be offering you today will be in
the form of
jackhammers in this first round of
competition you'll be forging blades in
your signature style using steel from
these jackhammers you will have 10
minutes to work on your design you will
have 3 hours to forge your blades good
luck blad Smiths your 10-minute design
window starts now I don't believe that
my focus last time was 100% on competing
I think my focus was on the experience
so this time I'm here to win my design
is a hybrid kri Bowie the kri is going
to give me the best chopping ability and
the Bowie hybrid it's going to give me a
better slicer like they're struggling to
get the bits out of these jackhammers
yeah I wonder what's going to happen
when they start
forging you son of a I got it I'm
planning on making a competition Chopper
would easily handle chopping wood and
should take a fish out no problem last
time I just kind of was in a full Panic
so this time I think I'm just going to
try and maintain a little bit more
composure and I think I'll do a lot
better I think I was invited back to
compete because I'm
beautiful coming back for a Redemption
it's three different guys brand new
different challenge anything's possible
I'm going to make a competition Chopper
because it's going to take a beating and
it has a little bit of curve to the edge
for
slicing blade Smith your 10-minute
design window is closed your three-hour
Forge time starts now pretty confident
that I have enough material to achieve
the shape of knife that I'm trying to
make so I cut off the sides of the bit
to make it easier to draw it out that's
not a good move a lot of times these
guys will cut off steel and then need it
later on
right now Eric I think he's done a great
job of forcing that blade down and
drawing it out so now he's got a nice
wide piece of Steel last time at this
point right here I was beating my head
against the wall trying to split my
stock that's probably the most difficult
way to do this type of w I was making
mistakes and not changing my course of
action I know that if I screw up if
something happens I'm off first again
and that is a pill I do not want to
swallow it's moving good everything's
working out the way it should and I've
already got the thing curving in the
right direction James is peeling off
layers the temperature is getting a
little warm oh get a tan my eyes
welding oh that's good right now I was
still pretty good last time it was when
I got to the grinder was when I had the
problem I realized that I'm drawing my
steel out thinner than the parameters
that I'd set for myself originally so I
need to alter my game plan that looks
good dude might turn out a little bit
skinny but I think it's still got enough
to do the job I'm going to rely more on
blade geometry than Mass to meet the
challenge Eric
quenched when my quench comes out and my
colors look great mine feels good so far
I think I got it mine hardened okay dude
I wouldn't say it's hard hard but uh it
skated Earl just quenched I do the
quench I get a little bit of
warpage it was initially pretty alarming
but with Morgan's experience with his
steel what I was predominantly worried
about was the hardness I mean it's
biting think it hardened at all nope if
this blade tries to chop wood and it's
not hardened it's going to fail the test
if my knife fails a test that means I'm
going home so I decided to test it in
the acid that's actually was very smart
the harden steel is going to color up
different than the softer steel wow
something happened I can see that where
I stopped my quench there is a
discernable difference between the steel
might not have gotten hard enough but
we'll never know till we actually test
it
out James his blades anti oiled yeah I
haven't seen him check the hardness he
didn't get the
memo checking I don't file test my blade
I'm pretty confident that it's hard
three two one blad Smith shut down your
machines this is the strength and
durability test I'll be taking your
blades and chopping into each of these
beams seven times remember this is not
about what happens to the wood this is
about what happens to your blade James
are you ready yes
sir last time I was on my blade broke so
I'm thinking thinking in my head please
please please perform
[Music]
well not bad at
all I like the blade design it lends
itself well to cutting but there is a
little bit of edge deformation here a
wire Edge that's kind of rolled over a
little bit oh man at this point there's
a chance that I could be going home Eric
are you ready let's do
[Music]
it well ER I like your blade shape but
when you leave the front of the handle
flat but you round off the back it is
very difficult to Index this knife but
no damage to your blade well done thank
you are you ready yes sir
good Earl I like the shape of your knife
and your handle feels very comfortable
but the problem is is your edge geometry
it's pushing its way in but it's not
really cutting its way in but no
damage next up is the sharpness test
blad bits I'm going to take your weapon
and slash across this fish if it's sharp
it should glide through James you're up
first you ready I'm ready
sir I'm feeling really cut nervous cuz I
don't know how well it's going to
perform because of that roll on my
Edge
when I grabbed onto your handle here it
fit nicely but when I start moving it
this way start to feel the edges right
here but it's definitely sharp enough to
cut through the fish your blade will cut
thank you Eric you're
up
one thing I love about it is the balance
there was no drag felt good it
felt like I chopped something so thank
you for that excitement the handle is
smooth there are no rough edges and it
will cut thank you Earl your turn you
ready I'm nervous right now I've made a
solid knife but I think it could be
sharper
[Music]
you have a stunning and beautiful
looking Blade the handle is smooth but
you can see some indentations right
there which shows that there might be an
area here that's not as sharp it didn't
Glide all the way through but your blade
will cut I just wanted to hear that with
as thin a blade as Earl had it should
have been a slicer I feel my chances of
moving on to round three might be
looking better
blade Smiths it's time for one of you to
leave the
forge erl your blade did not make the
cut Jason will explain Earl you made a
beautiful knife I love the shape of it
you had a good handle on it but you just
didn't grind it to produce the kind of
edge that you need to cut with when I
was doing the log shop it was bouncing
off of the wood it's just not sharp and
that's why we have to send you home I
understood please your blade it would
have been really nice to move on to the
final round but just wasn't in the cards
I had a chance to show what I could do
and that was way more than I did the
first time and as far as Redemption goes
that's about as much as I could ask for
right
there